the division shocked are the latest game
to be delayed until 2016 you guys are
all surprised no no no I mean we haven't
really seen what that game is we we have
we don't we don't know what it is last
year not the last year 28 three's ago
they showed us people on mobile with
tablets can come in and do like drone
strikes yeah where did that go we
haven't seen it since then last year's
e3 showing was great they shot really
cool trailer and the dude with the
flamethrowers they showed another sort
of playable I guess instance Amish and
gave us some more details but maybe how
that sort of world will work and it
always seemed like a game that wasn't
coming out this year but I feel like you
can never tell anymore because like
Assassin's Creed now we've seen
syndicate it's ad in October there are
all these rumors that fall out for being
at e3 and then some people are saying it
might think it'll come out this year
maybe we'll come out this year so what
to we could see watchdogs to before we
see the division yeah I've heard
watchdogs to might be taking place in
this old fair city as well gee rumors
flying SFO but here we have the division
slipping to next year do you think
that's a good call like in the past
Ubisoft have been criticized for having
games come a little bit early a little
buggy to the rough and they've
Assassin's Creed commanding in October
do you think this competes with that
state your uncle first no I was just
gonna say I think it's smart because we
all remember what happened with watch
dogs they have you have a PR campaign
right you're the PR campaign is meant to
build up hype and stuff like that so
they had obviously built to a certain
release date and then what happens is
you know it just you know you know the
wad is blown the height is done and then
suddenly like it's like whatever
watchdogs you know what I mean and so
then they have it I think it's smart you
know this this is not just good for game
development but it's also good for game
PR so you're saying is PR companies are
too quick to blow their wads when it
comes to talking about new games coming
out is that a new IP problem do you
think why because like for instance if
follow so follow sorry gross like all
that can be announcing they can make it
come out in four months because it's
fallout yes so do you think this is like
watch dogs they have to obviously like
plant that seed the division it kind of
do the same thing at the plant that seed
do you think this is just like an awful
byproduct of like PR trying to hype up
like new IP specifically like announcing
it years before it even comes out well I
think watch dogs became essentially
either became bigger than what they
initially thought or they realized that
they were too big and they had to scale
down look at the wii u version that came
out six months after everything else
came ubisoft though has demonstrated
that it is among all of the publishers
seems to be the most open about yep no
we're going to delay it because we don't
think it's ready they have been the most
open and the most willing to do that and
they were all they were even apologetic
about Assassin's Creed unity of the
start of the songs presentation they
were really there Jen they seemed
genuinely remorseful about it I mean
Assassin's Creed needs to come up they
have one coming out every year because
that is their annual series yeah watch
dogs got delayed twice a stick of truth
got delayed three times Wow um they
division is on a second delay I honestly
am NOT surprised and I think if they
feel if UV saw it feels that that game
is not ready i'm going to take their
word on it because they've done it
before cool well maybe this time next
year we'll be talking about add the
division with a bit more at detail but
for now our tech village
you
you